or banking stocks have tumbled in Europe
this morning as investors digest the
news while all eyes will be on U.S
lenders such as the Under Pressure First
Republic Bank when Wall Street opens in
a few hours time
having been Chief Financial Officer
during the last Global financial crisis
and well aware of the importance of a
solid balance sheet especially in
challenging Times Like These a new UBS
will remain Rock Solid UBS intends to
downsize credit suisse's Investment
Banking business and align it with our
conservative risk culture
well I was Colin Kelleher the chairman
of UBS I've been speaking with Dr
Muhammad al-airian he's president of
Queens College Cambridge and advisor to
alleons and Gramercy I began by asking
him whether the rescue of Credit Suisse
would be enough to shore up confidence
in the global banking system
the initial reactions of markets is
worry we see UBS stock being hit we see
UBS bonds being hit and we see a general
risk off tone
obviously as part of this Rescue an
entire class of credit Swiss bondholders
have been wiped out even though normally
they come higher up the the hierarchy
than shareholders who are getting
something out of this deal how worrying
a precedent is this for future such
rescues
what was puzzling is that the the most
Junior Bonds were wiped out as you say
while the equity was not completely
wiped out and that's making bondholders
wonder about the seniority you know this
seems like technical
um issues but it's not there are certain
rules that everybody thinks about being
followed and there's been this one very
puzzling treatment of these bonds that's
making people question what they thought
about the seniority of their Holdings
and that does store up trouble doesn't
it because potentially it makes these
bonds less attractive to hold in future
it does and we're seeing this in markets
today that people are recalibrating what
they thought the risk was
now the Federal Reserve and other
central banks have opened Daily Dollar
swap lines is that going to be enough to
ensure that lending continues we're not
going to see lending dry up as we did in
2008.
I fear that we're going to see lending
go down and credit becoming more
difficult for two reasons
one is that institutions will step back
because of all the uncertainty and the
most important priority today if you're
a financial institutions is to protect
your balance sheet you want a fortress
balance sheet which means take less risk
the second is most people expect
there'll be more regulation
and that in itself tends to dampen
credit creation so unfortunately the
economic contagion as opposed to the
financial contagion the economic
contagion is likely to be another
headwind to growth
and what about the position of some of
these U.S mid-tier and Regional lenders
in particular like First Republic
clearly this is not the end of The Saga
so far as they're concerned
it's not in
lots of phone calls over the weekend
from people with deposits in these Banks
and I kept on telling them your deposits
are safe and then they said well what do
I lose if I just move them to a bigger
bank that's too large to fail and it's
very difficult to counter that argument
so it is likely that these banks will
suffer deposit outflow but not for any
reason to do with them they just happen
to be in the wrong neighborhood and I
think the authorities need to move
really quickly and it's very easy to do
you formalize what you did for Silicon
Valley Bank for these other Banks
logically speaking then could that
ultimately result in a consolidation of
the U.S banking sector
it will but that's not a good thing um
the U.S banking system relies on these
Regional Banks and these smaller Banks
to serve local and Regional needs so
it's not a good thing I think you you
can stop this process from destabilizing
by simply saying that the deposit
insurance that was given to
the deposit is at Silicon Valley Bank is
now available to all banks
you mentioned that UBS shares have
obviously Fallen at the open by around
13 14
long term this is actually potentially a
very good deal for them isn't it
um it is as long as a they can deal with
what they've swallowed and they don't
get indigestion and the chairman of UBS
made it very clear that what they
swallowed was too big and he intends to
shrink it now shrinking is not easy so
that's that's number one and number two
was the question that was posed at this
fascinating press conference last night
to The Regulators what are you going to
do now when UBS and already big bank has
become even bigger what about the
Monopoly issues what about the two the
risk of too large to manage let alone
too large to fail so this is really
complex this was not a perfect solution
but it was the best of the Alternatives
available
how much of a dent is this to The
Prestige of Switzerland's banking sector
I mean after all Credit Suisse was one
of the very few Banks anywhere in the
world that was able to go toe-to-toe
with some of the Wall Street Giants
yeah I mean just step back and think Ian
the second largest bank in Switzerland
one that's been around for over 150
years one that was one of the 30
systemically important banks will no
longer exist that you know that was
Unthinkable two years ago three years
ago so it is a blow to The Prestige and
you could hear from the politicians
yesterday and from The Regulators that
one of the reasons why they moved like
as they moved they want to preserve
Switzerland's attraction as a financial
center
and I was supposed to obviously get to
rate decisions this week from the
Federal Reserve from the bank of England
and indeed the Swiss National Bank
markets were assuming a week or so ago
we get a quarter point raise in each of
those jurisdictions what do you think is
going to happen now
so what I think is going to happen for
um the banks is they're likely not to
hike interest rates in the case of the
Federal Reserve I think that's a mistake
I think the Federal Reserve should do
what the European Central Bank did last
week when it hiked by half a percentage
points making it very clear that
monetary policies directed interest rate
policies directed at inflation and the
other tools we have are directed at
Financial stability it is when you
co-mingle the two which the FED has done
too often in the past that you end up in
the model middle
and we're in this situation partly
because central banks around the world
were too slow to raise interest rates
last year I guess
yes I mean you know the image as I've
shared with you is that especially the
Federal Reserve was in a car driving on
a very foggy model way it should have
slowed down it didn't
by the time it it finally recognized
that it was in a fog that wasn't going
to be transitory their word it still
didn't slow down and then slammed on the
brakes are we surprised there are other
accidents on the motorway no we're not